Grande maison d'édition.
Ils ont perdu beaucoup d'argent une année,
et pendant 3 jours leur équipe dirigeante a visualisé toutes leurs méthodes.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est qu'après avoir visualisé
toute l'entreprise, système après système,
ils ont récupéré 50 millions de dollars de revenus,
et sont passés de la catégorie D à A de la part de leurs clients.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'il y a une cohérence au sein de l'équipe exécutive.
Ma mission aujourd'hui consiste à aider les organisations
à résoudre leurs problèmes épineux avec la visualisation collaborative,
et sur un site que j'ai réalisé, drawtoast.com,
j'ai collecté plein de bonnes pratiques,
pour vous permettre d'y apprendre comment diriger un workshop.
Vous pouvez en apprendre plus sur le langage visuel
et les structures de liens et nœuds applicables à la résolution de problèmes.
et télécharger des exemples de modèles
pour déballer les problèmes épineux auxquels nous faisons tous face.
Donc l'exercice de design de toast, en apparence trivial,
nous aide a être clairs, engagés et cohérents.
La prochaine fois que vous serez confrontés à un défi captivant,
rappelez-vous ce que nous a appris le design.
Rendez vos idées visibles, tangibles et significatives.
C'est simple, fun et puissant.
Je pense que c'est une idée qui vaut la peine d’être célébrée.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)